this is one of Europe's most important
energy projects a pipeline that will
connect an offshore gas import terminal
to the Greek grid this year the floating
storage and regasification unit or fsru
will be permanently anchored off
alexandropolis a northern Port that's
already a major hub for Western weapons
Bound for Ukraine most of the gas will
be re-exported to Southeast Europe
competing against Russian gas exports
there and depriving Russia of income the
Project's owners say Greece's potential
as a Gateway for non-russian gas is
enormous
should the Russia Russian gas
is totally discontinued from the region
including Hungary and Moldova we are
looking at a gap of 21 to 22 billion
cubic meters and if you add to that the
future demand of of Ukraine then we are
looking at a potential Market of about
50 to 55
billion cubic meters Greece is already
playing this role it operates the only
gas import terminal in the Balkans south
of Croatia and has supplied Bulgaria
since Russia cut off its gas supply last
year and more terminals are planned
Greece is building a small Fleet of
fsrus already the first one will come on
stream by December this year in
alexandropolis a second one construction
which is also going to start this year
is in Corinth in the motor oil refinery
and there are licenses for another two
one Thessaloniki and another one
alexandropolis and the fifth one coming
in Wallace all this makes Greece a
champion of the western boycott of
Russian energy but most people here say
they're not seeing the benefits even
this diversity and security of Supply
hasn't made energy cheap for Greek
consumers which is what matters in this
election new democracy did spend 15
billion dollars subsidizing energy bills
last year but much of that came from
taxes the decisions they made that will
really make a difference to people's
pockets was to drill for Greek gas but
that won't come onto the market for at
least four years in the meantime the
governing new Democracy party has
pursued energy autonomy from Renewables
it doubled electricity generation from
solar and wind power to cover 40 percent
of Greece's needs and plans to double
that if it wins another term this Sunday
the benefits of decarbonization and
Greece's geopolitical role against
Russia aren't lost on voters but there's
a danger that many will feel they're
paying a high price for that policy John
saropoulos Al Jazeera alexandropolis